monsieur le Président Mesdames les
ministres mes chers collègues monsieur
le Premier ministre vous avez fait une
déclaration de politique générale qui a
surjoulé le volontarisme drappé dans la
nouveauté qu'inspire votre nomination
récente vous semblez découvrir une
situation dans laquelle ni vous ni
Emmanuel Macron n'auriez aucune
responsabilité un bilan dont vous ne
seriez pas comptable ainsi sous couvert
de modernité de jeunesse votre logiciel
politique est daté obsolète voilà que la
crise agricole lancinante et menace
depuis des décennies vous saute à la
figure les ravages du libre échange
d'une politique bruxelloise déconnectée
des réalités du monde paysan d'un
gouvernement rester sour au CR de colère
et de désespoir tous ces mots que le
rassemblement national dénonce depuis
longtemps vous semblez les découvrir
aujourd'hui alors que nos agriculteurs
convergent vers Paris dans un mouvement
pacifique et pleinement soutenu par les
Français Monsieur le Premier Ministre
tous ceux qui ont échoué depuis 10 ans
de gauche comme de droite vous les avez
soutenu d'une manière ou d'une autre
vous avez été incapable par par
idéologie et par conformisme de résister
à un libre échange délirant comment
peut-on encore vous croire en sachant
que la feuille de route ultralibérale
continuera à être déroulé dans les mois
les années à venir comment pourz
pourrez-vous rétablir la la confiance
alors que vous êtes comptable d'cun
dirait coupable du malheur de nos
paysans Monsieur le Premier Ministre
vous parlez d'action vous accumulez les
déplacements mais vous ne pouvez rien
faire parce que vous voulez vous lesbrez
pas d'entrav confortabl d'entraves qui
permettent de systématiquement rejeter
la responsabilité des échecs c'est à
Bruxelles que se dcine notre politique
agricole et c'est là tout le problème
français le pouvoir politique n'existe
plus il est dilué abandonné par les
politiques eux-mêmes et nos compatriotes
l'ont bien compris Bruxelles décide et
les Français subissent c'est là c'est ce
qui caractérise aujourd'hui le système
dont vous êtes tenant c'est
l'impuissance qu'enti à ce titre comment
ne pas revenir sur la question
sécuritaire et migratoire sur la
poursuite en 2023 de l'immigration
massive sur la nonexécution des OQTF
avec leur lot de drame sur les émeutes
qui ont enflammé le Pay pays en juillet
Monsieur le Premier Ministre vous
évoquez hier à juste titre votre
saatisfaction de pouvoir être Premier
ministre et homosexuel assumé en 2024
monsieur le Premier ministre
permettez-moi de sortir de l'immédiateté
et de vous poser une question si le
laxisme sécuritaire migratoire perdure
pensez-vous que nous pourrons encore
assumer notre homosexualité en 2034 je
l'espère et cette question me permet de
soulever le drame de nos compatriote qui
s'aggrave chaque année un peu plus 7 ans
de macronie c'est 7 ans de précarité
c'est endre in capacité pour nos
compatriotes à se projeter à faire des
sacrifices et des compromis parce que
leur pouvoir d'achat et la site de
mesquinerie permanente et l'exécutoire
du quoi qu'il en coûte Monsieur le
Premier Ministre vous nous avez fait
l'image hier d'une France idéale mais
être français en 2024 c'est aussi avoir
du mal à boucler ses fins de mois et
quelquefois même les débuts de mois être
en en 2024 c'est ne pas trouver de place
dans un dans un institut spécialisé pour
y placer son enfant en situation de
handicap vos promesses Monsieur le
Premier Ministre n'y changeront rien
votre communication léchée ne nous fera
pas oublier la réalité et votre bilan
votre gouvernement demeure minoritaire
dans les chambres comme dans le pays
Monsieur le Premier Ministre prenons
date et dans 6 mois 1 an 2 ans nous
faisons le par que rien Nura changé les
Français veent des acteurs au quotidien
pas les témoins du déclin je vous
remercie
merci
monsieur